absolut ein sehr emotionales thema mich
bewegt eine verpasste chance für
deutschland die ampel verzichtet auf
eine steuerreform die den namen verdient
hätte unser steuersystem das bleibt
extrem kompliziert bleibt ungerecht und
die belastung der bürgerinnen und bürger
bleibt eine der höchsten in der ganzen
welt jetzt wird eine weitere
legislaturperiode vergehen ohne dass
diese missstände angepackt werden die
fdp hat steuererhöhungen verhindert das
natürlich gut ganz generell waren die
liberalen ihr senat bollwerk der
vernunft gegen grüne und rote
träumereien aber mit ihrer forderung
nach einem besseren steuersystem da
konnten sich die fdp nicht durchsetzen
und das geht zu lasten der arbeitenden
bevölkerung in diesem land und ich mache
die probleme mal an zwei beispielen ganz
konkret erstens meine erträge aus
capital also meine aktienrenditen die
muss sich versteuern mit einer
25-prozentigen abgeltungsteuer meinen
lohn als angestellter muss ich mit bis
zu 42 prozent spitzensteuersatz
versteuern das ist ungerecht weil für
die aktienrendite musste ich ja gar
nicht arbeiten zweites beispiel und das
macht mich eigentlich noch wütender
gerade im bereich niedriger und
mittlerer einkommen da steigt die
steuerlast besonders schnell an dh von
gehaltserhöhungen
da greift sich der staat besonders viel
ab das wiederum heißt der finanzielle
aufstieg der lohnt sich nicht so wie er
es eigentlich müsste und das ist eine
ungerechtigkeit die seit jahrzehnten
besteht mittlerweile und die wieder
nicht angefasst wird um eines ganz klar
zu sagen ich finde der ampel vertrag der
steht in vielen themen für einen echten
aufbruch wo das ist gut kommen gleich
dazu aber nicht bei den steuern und das
ist schlecht und um 1 auch ganz klar zu
sagen mir geht es natürlich nicht darum
dass der staat weniger einnehmen soll
oder dass man spitzenverdiener wirklich
entlasten sollte mir geht es um
einfachheit und um gerechtigkeit in
einem wirklich renovierungsbedürftigen
system und die ampel die hätte hier
handeln müssen wenn ihr denkt ich muss
sagen doch mir geht es hier um ich finde
wir sollten entlastet werden und ich
finde auch dass rück auch
spitzenverdiener entlastet werden dürfen
da gibt es einen grund zwar sich bei
ersten sagen möchte ist christian
lindner im koalitionsvertrag da was ich
ihnen jetzt mal loben ist trägt eine
klare liberale handschrift er war da
schon das bollwerk gegen den linksruck
aber trotzdem die steuer steuern genau
nicht mehr steuern aber ich glaube da
war auch nicht so viel zu gewinnen also
insgesamt hat er den koalitionsvertrag
finde ich sehr gut ausgehandelt er
können die liberalen schon sagen gut
gemacht so oft ja also das muss ich erst
sagen aber sie sagen wer als letztes ist
wir können die steuern ruhig senken weil
weiß was mich so stört die steuerreform
der kriege ich gar nicht so temperatur
zu aber wenn ich mir überlege was der
staat alles einnimmt ich finde der staat
ist ein wahnsinnig schlechter
unternehmer und das hat jetzt auch
wieder die korona krise gezeigt auch
ganz viele andere projekte und ich
glaube wenn der staat anfangen würde
besser zu wirtschaften bräuchten wir gar
nicht so viel steuereinnahmen also mir
wird manchmal schlecht wenn ich über
projekte wie der lese wo millionen wie
in st gießkannenprinzip abhanden
gekommen ist würde ich gerne aber frau
befreien weil die bei einem politik
nicht sprechen darüber und kommentieren
ist immer einfacher als machen also eher
wie geht denn der staat mit den
steuergeldern ja gut es gibt ja immer
diese überprüfung wo wirklich
steuergelder verschwendet worden sind wo
dann eine straße gebaut worden ist wenn
man feststellt die instinkte ins nirvana
fbl führt also das gibt es immer leider
leider immer noch aber man muss auch so
sehen der staat ist natürlich auch der
größte öffentliche auftraggeber mit über
200 milliarden euro jedes jahr wo
natürlich auch in die wirtschaft geht
natürlich auch arbeitsplätze und alles
generiert wird aber wir müssen natürlich
eine sind durch moral allein bekommen
wir kein wachstum sondern wachstum
machen natürlich die unternehmen und
wenn man die letzten umfragen wird dies
vom ausland auch über den standort
deutschland gemacht worden sind zeigt
sich leider dass wir am sinken es sind
vorher waren noch 38 prozent von großen
vorstellen von unternehmen haben sie
haben wir kann in deutschland
investieren wir sind auf 19 prozent
herab gegangen also das heißt und die
begründung war auch einer der gründe war
auch ihm dass nicht wettbewerbsfähige
steuersystem was wir haben wir haben
heute auch im vergleich zu europäischen
nachbarn haben wir durchschnitts
arbeitskosten pro stunde also es
38,6 während andere unsere nachbarländer
25,5 euro pro stunde haben also wir sind
als hochsteuerland überhaupt auch in
in ganz europa und wenn wir heute
schaffen wollen und wir haben fachkräfte
gemacht also dass wir die klügsten die
intelligentesten köpfe auch bekommen
nach deutschland was wir auch brauchen
damit wir im internationalen wettbewerb
mithalten können dann müssen wir
natürlich ein wettbewerbsfähiges
steuerrecht haben
sie haben recht schick er hat gut
verhandelt dahin gehen dass es nicht zu
steuererhöhungen
offiziell kommt da es ist also ist
wirklich was vorbeigehen aber wir haben
natürlich steuererhöhungen durch die
hintertür das darf man auch nicht
vergessen weil es soll dazu auch im
sogenannten subventions
anführungsstriche was man auch darunter
immer versteht abbau comment was ja auch
indirekt nicht steuererhöhung ist
seit 10.2 preis war
ja er hat sich durchgesetzt weil es gab
eine pattsituation also im grunde
genommen hat dass du zwei
koalitionspartner die wollten eigentlich
die steuern erhöhen vor allen dingen für
besserverdienende und lindner hat sich
durchgesetzt und hat sein
durchgeboxt das ist keine
steuererhöhungen kommt wobei ich fürchte
dabei hat er geopfert dass man
vielleicht ein bisschen rum spielt und
die eine oder andere steuer erhöht und
dafür andere steuern senkt durch diese
pattsituation haben sie das spielfeld
komplett leer lassen das thema ist doch
momentan dramatischen je die inflation
macht uns alle sorgen momentan und
natürlich spielt eine ganz gewaltige
rolle wie viel steuern in grenzen wenn
meine kaufkraft jeden monat ab nimmt die
zahlen diese woche waren ja dramatisch
also das thema hängt doch am ende
irgendwie zusammen und es wäre doch gar
nicht so kompliziert gewesen man hätte
den steuersatz den spitzensteuersatz
später anfangen lassen können zb 58.000
euro jahresgehalt gehalt zahlt man den
spitzensteuersatz das ist doch kein
spitzen gehalt das ist das 1 4-fache des
deutschen durchschnitts bruttolohns das
kann doch nicht sein gleichzeitig die
ungerechte behandlung von niedrigen
einkommen ich habe es in einem statement
erwähnt dass es auch eine
ungerechtigkeit man könnte den
steuersatz linearisierung sagt man also
diese diese bogenform wegnehmen den
sogenannten mittelstandsbauch
sozusagen rausnehmen es gibt so
offensichtlich der handel aber
abgeflacht worden als er das nicht ist
ja immer noch da ist so offensichtlich
sind an den eher wird man würde sagen
ein nobler warum hat man das nicht an
jetzt vergehen wieder vier jahre ist
werden steuer technisch wieder vier
vergangene verlorene jahre sein
grenzenlose als ergänzung was das
schlimme ist normalerweise wird weil die
inflation wir haben eine wahnsinnig hohe
inflation was natürlich gerade die
ärmere bevölkerung sehr sehr stark
trifft weil die gleiches geld aus ihr
geld aus wie heizung gas strom und und
lebensmittel und es wurde ihnen
normalerweise wird die provision nach
ausgeglichen und scholz stellt sich hin
und sagt er will jetzt die inflation mal
beobachten und mal sehen wie sie dann
nächstes jahr ist und dann muss man halt
dann eventuell handelt also ich sage so
kann man nicht agieren du musst dir auf
jeden fall mein
plan b also von von olaf scholz eine
klare aussage zu
ich finde dass hochgeht herauszulocken
ist quasi unmöglich meine ich habe als
er unsere sendung gesehen hat mit ihm
wer als paul im interview
kniete ich vorm fernseher gab fehlte nur
ein klaren satz nur einen satz denn ich
hatte die chance ja
ich hab ich habe innerlich geknetet
bitte bitte bitte sag einen klaren satz
wenigstens bei bild zeigt einen klaren
satz das würde die bildet sich sofort in
mein leben mein herze würde ich sofort
in mein herz abnehmen ich finde mich
unsympathisch ich finde ich träume auch
wirklich zu ein guter kanzler zu sagen
aber ich wünsche mir von einem kanzler
ein klares deutsch er muss fähig sein
auch die bevölkerung anzusprechen und
das kann er fit ist wird er mit diesen
schachtelsätzen nicht erreichen aber
dass du mir weit weg vom thema ich kann
nur sagen wenn du je eine partei gründet
ich stehe ich verstehe nichts von
steuern also ich könnte nichts mehr aber
ich will deine wenige kerl ist liste
würde ich sofort blind blind unterstützt
mangel zusammenwächst alexander pick
liste ich glaube alexander sogar richtig
gut für die per muss ich sagen also ich
glaub ich mir wenn ich bleiben sprichst
du sprichst zum beispiel über
komplizierte themen in einer klaren
nachvollziehbaren sprache selbst
wirtschaftspolitische themen bin ich bin
der ich vertrau dir aus dem ich verstehe
nichts davon aber aus dem bauch heraus
muss ich dir sagen ich verstehe jedes
wort was du sagst das ist schon mal ein
riesenfortschritt in den haag